he's a guy that can stop the run
you can drop in coverage he
can rush the passer I guess what
I think he's going to be
a free agent
on body
about so we're doing okay how
does one feel for you guys
all by Cabey said it best for me
not to prove anybody wrong
Robert Russell right you know
how good we are in a locker
room and
we came out here played a brand
of football and we knew this was
what was gonna happen
what was the game plan going in
because it seems like you guys
kept two safeties deep you don't
want to give up the big
play and allow your front does
get up the quarterback
yeah nah we knew coming into
this game that you know for
Cardiff is that success are
front was going to have to
impact the game at a high level
%HESITATION you know we came in
and we were able to do that you
know so and so
go
in here we would just stay with
you top three in the entire NFL
impressions of those pressures
come from how do you think
about
getting after the quarterback
this year I'm just by
just cutting loose and just
plain as fast as I can play you
know that something like that
it's a mistake and you know
coming into this on to same a
man cut it loose play
relentless and that's another
life under appreciated thing
about
about a player maybe just play
hard good things happen
%HESITATION and that's one thing
you know
our culture is built on that
%HESITATION just plain as far
as you can and you know I
thought as a mother what
vehicle travel really likes
about you %HESITATION Herald is
the fact that you're very
versatile you can stop the run
you could drop in coverage
you can rush the passer talk
about
talk to us about your
versatility and is that
something that you continue to
work on
yeah not so like %HESITATION you
know I take pride in my
versatility I feel like you know
that's something that
could keep me you know this game
for a long time
%HESITATION but yeah like versus
our looks you know I can
beat it and I could be to the
off the ball linebacker and
outside linebacker dropping
coverage
like you said stop the run and
rush the passer so
now let's talk about that
contract
for some of the conversation
what is some of the leaders on
this team say after Derrick
Henry the king was out
yeah and I mean you can't
replace their medically to be
such a special player what he
did for this team but we also
have the next man up mentality
and you know going into this
game and
I just thought we compared our
.... off we came out here we
executed the game plan we
executed the game plan of
the coaches gave us and this is
what happens we do that
I brought to talk about Jeffrey
Simmons to Jeffrey Simmons
Moffett me he's the he's one of
those guys he's a really really
good player
but he doesn't get enough
respect
%HESITATION well I'm telling you
just a dog eat dog now and I
the thing that that people might
not see menaces leader so
like he knows the expectation
that we have here in this
culture that you know we have
here Hey does everybody today
standard no matter who it is
and he just put on display
tonight like
what he's about and I'm sorry
he's a dog you know I'm not I'm
not gonna be a play next on the
seat with her coach very will
talk about you as the unsung
hero in this defense would you
categorize yourself is that
Hey I just try to do my job at a
high level
Zacks already on the season here
%HESITATION Herald and
that ties a career high for you
do you set goals as far as how
many you're looking to achieve
in a season
I'm just trying to go out there
and play the game every single
game and
okay I'll feel like I'm playing
the ball right now but I'm
gonna keep going keep friends a
long season left and hopefully
we can turn it into a sponsor
your help because Kevin fired
buyer may the best safety in
National Football League and
he's just making plays but keep
but he's been making since he's
been on leave in %HESITATION
Cabey is as
is as consistent as economy so
that every single week man
and he's like he's another guy
and he's a great leader in our
locker room hello there but it's
a high standard he comes
I and does this thing every
single week and you know like
I said I'm
lucky enough to play with Jeff
on
even happier to play K. B. man
give us a sense for coach for a
full coach revel in
the attitude he instilled in
this team might give us a sense
how
he actually gives you guys that
out of the
nominees is that in their life
no matter who we play no matter
what's on where is that then
he gives us a game plan we go
out there and executed and like
that's the mantra that we had in
it it don't matter what
the situation is we don't
prepare as often come out and
play our
brand of football and that's
what it's about
thank you man we appreciate your
good luck this season the way
back across the country